пора переписувати всю візію світу в
якому не було України А чому ви вирішили
що Росія вічно чому поляки зразу ж
покохали Зеленського це не є нова книжка
Оксани Забужко це є воєнна служба Оксана
Забужко
[музика]
Оксана дякую що знайшли для нас час вас
війна застала в Європі і з тих пір як я
розумію ви не часто були в Україні ви
багато спілкуєтеся з іноземцями про те
що що зараз відбувається в Україні
виступали в європарламенті скажіть як за
вашими спостереженнями Чи змінилося
ставлення Європейців до українців
спочатку війни я Не розповідаю в
іноземцям що робиться в Україні я
розповідаю їм що вони пропустили в
своєму житті
що в результаті зараз ось зараз в 2022
році мусять прокидатися протирати очі
усвідомлювати собі що війна
російсько-українська війна по-перше не
24 лютого почалася а
принаймні 8 років на 8 років раніше я
розмовляю з західною аудиторією не
розповідаючи значить у типу який ми
класні які ми класні вони самі побачили
і вони самі знають за нас говорить ЗСУ
найкраще і найпереконливіше говорить
тому що народ який має таку армію от він
уже нічого не потребує доводити світові
от це це говорить само За себе я говорю
про те що пора переписувати всі
підручники
з європейської історії принаймні щоб
пора переписувати всю візію світу в
якому не було України ми зараз з вами
знаходимось в Берліні як на вашу думку
змінилася позиція німців чи помічаєте ви
це коли з ними спілкуєтесь німецька
аудиторія звикла сприймати Росію як
головоного
головного сусіда Вони все ще так
сприймають це підручниках написано
розумієте в шкільних і в
університетських тобто те що це треба Ну
це треба інакше Якось міняти окуляри от
розуміння що треба якось інакше що треба
щось з цим міняти бо діалоги що А що ж
аж всеодно ж нам потім доведеться жити з
Росії і потім і тут приїздить Забужко і
каже А чому ви так вирішили
А чому ви вирішили що Росія вічна Чому
ви вирішили що вона не розпадає ця от
Саме зараз і це і є та історична фаза
яка триває власне уже століття ці корчі
імперії і всі ті проекції і все те що
Путін вивалював вам на адресу України це
насправді проекції
кажучи фройдівською мовою його
внутрішніх страхів Щодо його власної
країни котра виявилася справді і країна
404 і фейл в Стейт але ви навіть не
помітили того ви не помітили вони
звернули увагу кажу я при оказії там в
кожному своєму інтерв'ю Ви не звернули
увагу що скажімо про тести значить оці
жіночі протести проти мобілізації
будь-коли Путін оголосив мобілізацію 21
вересня і значить нібито хвиля протестів
не хвилі Але були ці жіночі протести в
Росії вони не в Росії були не були в
Якутії і на Кавказі ці жіночі протести
Тобто це це речі котрі пов'язані рашими
імен протести ні Якутія мінве протислі
яку тінь війни протестували проти того
що їхніх мужчин забирають а забирають
справді з потенційно з регіонів
потенційно здатних до самостійного
існування тобто у вас на очах Путін
одночасно вирішує свою внутрішню
проблему значить цією війною вирішує і
проблему розпаду регіонів Ну ви
розумієте що значить що там перед 24
лютого скажімо
до цього б не прислухалися І коли ти
говориш помаленьку поступово крок за
кроком але ти але тим людям пояснює що
Росія не вічна і розпад Росії якраз не
уникне шкільний і не треба його
гальмувати його не треба гальмувати його
можна його треба взяти можна і треба
взяти
під міжнародний контроль щоб він
відбувався мирно з мінімальною шкодою
для сусідів принаймні так
от або це процес не на рік і не на два
Зрозуміло Але це велика транс-велика
історична трансформація Уявляти собі що
оце значить Давайте давайте оце Значить
тут зараз типу швидко мирні переговори
ми це все закінчимо ми назад це все
криваве м'ясо значить заштовхаємо що там
воскресимо воскресимо мертвих Ні ну
цього не обіцяють Так але в усьому
іншому то типу давайте вернемося до
вернемося назад до значить От і все буде
знову добре Ні не буде добре не буде
добре бо Росія розпадається силою
власної історичної інер Росії і ви
взагалімували Маючи на увазі колективний
захід цю історичну енергію в 90-ті коли
процес пішов після розпаду Радянського
Союзу Татарстан і Чечня оголосили
незалежність і він би й далі тоді цей
процес ішов от але ви злякалися значить
відповідно вся та допомога Росії Яка
тоді йшла з заходу Вона стояла на тому
щоб утримати Росію в її нинішніх
кордонах не повторюйте цією помилки вона
цим разом людству коштуватиме значно
дорожче ніж минулого разу і коштуватиме
як мінімум екологічної катастрофи зараз
Вони слухають і зараз вони починають
звикати до цієї думки але ця думка
насправді для заходу дуже нова причому
не тільки для Німеччини вона нова ось
зараз коли ви кажете що ця думка нема і
вона ще має зійти і
прищепитися так прищепитися оскільки
маємо про часу що в цей час має робити
Україна як держава
українське суспільство українські митці
для того щоб ця думка стала
каталізатором змінної підручників
історії як ви кажете а це має бути
частиною державної політики привчати
західні еліти політичні культурні
інтелектуальній академічні привчати їх
до думки що
це величезна ілюзія що після цього Росія
ж нікуди не дінеться як після цього
головне розумієте в що вони вперлися от
яка логічна помилка в що вони всі
вперлися рогом дискусії точаться ну
навіть між інтелектуалами як захід от
вишколений за тими підручниками за якими
вискулений розумієте Як в Західній еліти
ставлять питання чи можлива
демократизація чи можливість зміни Росії
те що позитивом буде без Росії А Путін
це знав коли він казав за чим нам мір з
Росії це теж страх проговорений
вихоплений назовні це страх розпаду ось
цей страх розпаду який обговорювався і
Серед російських Еліт з тих самих 90-х
років починаючи Тобто Ну я знаю людей
які брали в цьому участь і зрештою ці
мапи Росії там намальовані різними
кольорами перспективі значить які де там
регіони утворяться так би мовити Це не
українці малювали їм Розумієте це це
середини все-таки якогось цього не
добитого ще і недодавленого гаснучого
російського розуму з'являлися Якісь ці
позитивні значить конструктивні імпульси
що що треба це розпустити і це буде
краще такий для населення цих територій
я під цим оглядом всілякого аплодую е-е
скажімо тому що шкірі Його визнали
окупованою територією так е-е в жовтні
було рішення Верховної Ради України на
цю тему воно не отримує той медіальної
до медіального висвітлення в західних
ЗМІ Яке би вартувало але принаймні
значить якась ну є позиція Української
держави є ця позиція ніби що ми
підтримуємо ми підтримуємо ці
національно-визвольні рухи Ми
підтримуємо значить
міграції Вони переважно знаходяться ті
котрі контролюють
Ну якось виступають речниками ось цих
поневолених народів ми підтримуємо
поневолені народи Росії ця позиція має
бути належним чином медіалізована А це
позиція має бути належним чином
систематизована і її треба постійно
промивати назовні її треба при кожних
оказіях не боятися не боятися не
примилятися не впадати в річ не
намагатися сподобатися
пояснювати людям чого вони не розуміють
Ми зараз в тій позиції коли ми маємо їм
пояснювати тому що ми за них воюємо ми є
ось тим Перепрошую значить відважним
дядьком який б'ється з бандитом на
порозі їхнього дому а вони нам
періодично з вікна там викидаю
підкидають то ножика то шматочки ковбаси
розумієте але але не набагато більше Ну
самі казали в одному з коментарів що
захід має прокинутись бо вони прийдуть
до вас війна прийде до вас У вас є
відчуття що тут люди розуміють цей
напевно можна це сказати про е-е Польщу
про країни Балтії
країни Балтії відразу увімкнулися Вони і
не вимикалися прямо скажемо тобто в
цьому сенсі ми ми опиняємося знову під
оглядом безпеки зараз от дуже цікавий
процес насправді для істориків дуже
цікава Я думаю має бути у під оглядом
безпеки ми вернулися
вернулися Велике Князівство Литовське от
В цьому безпековому плані в плані
відчуття що це наша армія в тому
розумінні що вона нас захищає
отут Та отут знаєте
відчуття українців і відчуття литовців
і відчуття поляків Там трошки складніше
чому поляки зразу ж зразу ж покохали
Зеленського травма вересня 39 коли
польський уряд
відсолютувавши розумієте польському
народу по вантажився в автомобілі і
рвонув у Румунії
польський уряд втік
а тут розумієте от можна скільки
завгодно там іронізувати з цього приводу
але
Перепрошую Це справді виявилося ну
історично переконливим і одна фраза що
мені не треба таксі мені треба зброї
все це даруйте Ну не знаю хто автор
фрази Чи це сам президент чи це
співчурайтери такі фрази входять справді
в підручники історії цього одного
вистачило бо зарезонувало своїм
історичним болем з ось тим самим що
Польщу втратили після того як втік уряд
тобто Насправді це дуже цікаві процеси
мені Софії Оксана наприклад розказувала
потім що 24 лютого у Фінляндії була ну
хвиля паніки у старечих притулках дуже
багато цих
значить старичків які пам'ятали зимову
війну 40-го року дітьми
пам'ятали от вони вирішили що це знову
Росія напала на Фінляндію
і вони в паніці дзвонили своїм внукам і
правнукам з інструкціями як там Чим
запасатися куди бігти Як рятуватися іде
в матраці зашиті якісь там значить
золоті монети Тобто ви розумієте яке
відбувається розгальмовування ось цієї
гальванізації колективної травми яка всі
ці 80 з гаком років от там сиділа в цій
підсвідомості Звичайно що Звичайно що
Фінляндія яка весь цей час боялася Росії
от вона негайно попросилася в НАТО тобто
Ось ця я би навіть сказала більше це не
просто Велике Князівство Литовське а це
це така мазепина Європа от проступає Ось
ця сама з варягу реки
від
від Швеції до Молдови знаєте ось цією от
смугою
оцією смугою внутрі солідарності і
розуміння от розуміння процесів саме як
таких котрі безпосередньо мають стосунок
от до нашої історії а щодо починаючи
скажімо з Німеччини
західної колишньої західної Німеччини і
далі тут складніше для мене наприклад
для мене наприклад знаєте такими
вимовними епізодами є це блекаут у
паризькому готелі от Минулого тижня
Тобто реакція портьє значить в якому я
сказала що я з України Значить і я Ну
так напівжартом що думала мовляв що що
це вже російська ракета і тут от і те як
він це сказав
зітхнувши ж спекти ну сподіваюся що ні
без тіні гумору без тіні ніби от значить
абсолютно не сприймаючи це як жарт от це
мені скажімо інше сказало про настрої
французької французького простолюду
страх перед Росією він по-різному
артикулюється в різних країнах підбивати
під один спільний знаменник дуже складно
би виявилося що в кожної країни в
кожного народу своя історія
свої своя історія скажемо так
колективних травм пов'язаних з Росією
пов'язаних зі східною Європою пов'язаних
з радянським союзом і все це зараз разом
от прийшло в рух і з цим усім от кожній
країні з осібна треба працювати Звичайно
що ми маємо їм допомогти ви тут з
презентацією книги е Найдовша подорож
Яку реакцію вона викликає у іноземців
які читають ви знаєте я зараз за
українськими стежу тому що тому що слава
богу значить шостим вдається завданням
такі українські нарешті вийшло при тому
що воно друкувалося в Харкові друкарні в
Харкові коли вони там коли могли тоді
працювали знаєте Ну мені насправді
завжди цікавіше реакція української
аудиторії чесно завжди от е-е Ну але
оригінально звичайно Ну стартову книжка
призначалася для аудиторії західної в
березні надійшла пропозиції віднауді
одного з найкращих власне другого
найбільшого видавництва Італії
з тим яке як я яке яке б хотіло купити
ну власне і збиралося купити е-е музей
покинутих секретів і вже не пам'ятаю що
там ще Ну дві книжки мої Вони хотіли
купити і значить Вони сказали А давайте
третю давайте третю Але яка має бути
написана прогнозувалося що на осінь буде
просто величезна Злива книжок про
Україну вийшла тільки Злива біографія
Зеленського насправді тобто в дійсності
Ось ця сама значить моя Найдовша подорож
Вона опинилася не те що поза
конкуренцією Вона опинилася мало не в
однині Як це не драматично
і для
насамперед Я думаю це для України
драматично бо звичайно всі ті іноземні
автори так чи інакше пов'язані з
Україною вони відмітилися в цьому потоці
ну відкрили ніби так насправді це ну
таке трохи ну так трохи драматично
скажемо так що з українців поки що
переклали Нівроку значить оці воєнні
щоденники тобто те що на швидку те що на
коліні те що пишеться тепер і вже і так
далі Це була перша от в моєму житті за
всю мою кар'єру літературну А це
все-таки 20 з гаком не пам'ятаю там
скільки книжок так о це була перша
книжка яка була замовлена ззовні
розумієте от не з внутрішньої потреби не
задуму не з того що я там значить це
хочу написати а це було От е-е от треба
треба це історії так Дві історії
подорож моя і дві два рівні подорожей
моєї країни
тридцятилітня після розпаду Радянського
Союзу і 300 літня після того як наші
предки
створили Російську імперію чи Тупак
модернізували московію своє ім'я навіть
Русь їй вділившись тобто те що вона
зараз себе по світу Ну по Європі
принаймні значить те що вона стає ось
цим Ну ніби таким та головним джерелом
інформації про цю війну про її контексти
культурно-історичні головною заявкою
якраз на оцю зміну дискурсу ось зміну
наративу західного наративу викликом
значить обґрунтуванням потреби
переписувати підручник це не є нова
книжка Оксани Забужко це є воєнна служба
Оксани Забужко письменниці так в Європі
часто проходять дискусії куди всі
організатори намагаються запросити Як
звести до купи сторін конфлікту так би
мовити
[музика]
хочу дізнатись вашу думку але хочу ще
сказати ось Олександра Матвійчук яка
виступала на вручені Нобелівської премії
вона виступилась чудовою промовою і
склалося враження що коли українці
відмовляються від участі в дискусіях або
відмовляються виходити на одну сцену з
представниками країн-агресорок що вони
позбавляють себе права голосу Яка ваша
думка щодо цього чи є ситуації коли ми
все-таки маємо погоджуватись на такі
пропозиції Не треба розглядати цей кейс
як за охоту далі з'являтися значить на
сцені там поруч із росіянами мені
зрозуміли які можуть бути претензії до
меморіалу окрім того що вшановувати їх
було було б актуально років 20 Тому
зараз вони не існуючі організації яка
ніякого впливу на ситуацію всередині
Росії немає і тому звичайно ж недобре
пахло це
триспальне ліжко скажемо так ця премія
для трьох народів братів і і те що воно
було сприйнято кому раносаліс м'яко
кажучи
українців українців не дуже були
задоволені тим що нас запхнули значить у
цей самий у цей самий гурт з трьох
братніх народів от оце більше ніж
виправдано і політично можна собі уявити
що на місці скажімо значить меморіалу
були були би скажімо іранські
правозахисниці це б тоді не сприймалося
як як значить спроба об'єднати різні
сторони і поставити Ну як цей прости
Господи значить папа під одним хрестом
українку і росіянку поставити Так це
тоді так не сприймалося але Річ у тому
що що це все одно ну це незалежні він
може бути поділений там Між ким завгодно
в принципі це не є спроба звести цих
людей разом для діалогу і розмови
Олександра Матвійчук отримала свою
трибуну вийшла на цю трибуну і
продемонструвала всім зацікавленим
колосальний розрив продемонструвала що
Україна не Росія з такою страшною силою
продемонструвала такий розрив
у політичній культурі на відстані в
мегабарсеки тобто якщо їй відсунули
попередню рамочку вона її не тільки
розбила вона її перевернула цю рамочку
і в результаті відпадає Хто там був ще і
залишається її промова це важливі тези
Це важлива позиція це дуже важливо з
такої трибуни вперше прозвучало нарешті
в контексті тої війни те що досі ми
говорили тільки на кухнях так що криза
всіх міжнародних інституцій Що робимо
тільки для сурус Значить ось
правозахисні організації які можуть між
собою горизонтально солідаризуватися вже
в глобальному масштабі А ми знаємо як це
робиться Ми українці у нас був Майдан
Все тобто поширення Майдану Як моделі
ефективного функціонування цілої планети
вау
вау все от слово сказане значить формулу
знайдено блискуче Прекрасно А хто там ще
поруч стояв в цей час там міг стояти хто
завгодно Це не має ніякого значення ви
розумієте що це абсолютно
ніяким чином немає ніякого відношення до
спроб скажімо Ну раз ми в Німеччині то
значить нам до німецький приклад
запросити в одну програму Оксано Забужко
і Людмилу вулізкою або британці мене
законами пробували запросити так і ніяк
не могли зрозуміти теж довелося довго
пояснювати себто не справді те що
десятки якщо не сотні значить
українських
митців інтелектуалів журналістів в
від кінця лютого починаючи
пояснювали вчили західні інституції
значить чому не можна
запрошувати разом на одну сцену
українців з росіянами коли мене просили
з шишкіним зустрітися на одному значить
із міжнародних ярмарків типу з'їсти
сісти разом для діалогу за один стіл Я
сказала я з ним можу сісти тільки там в
Барі на першому поверсі от значить
цілком можу випити по чарочці чому ні
тобто цілком позитивна людина позитивно
наставлена і і хороший письменник в барі
без питань на сцені Ні вони
говорять мали мікрофон
всі попередні роки нашого життя
десятиліття І століття до нашого життя
поки ми мовчали зараз коли ми отримали
мікрофон а ми його отримали українці
слухають зараз українцям дають слово так
от ми зараз частину цього мікрофона
знову віддаємо завойованого для нас між
іншим кров'ю пролитою
віддаємо цей знову мікрофон і ми знову
опиняємося в позиції бек-вокалу
бо як тільки поруч опиняється росіянин
розмова знову увага перетягується знову
на росіянина автоматично він перетягує
на себе ковдру хоч би тому що його
літературу вчили всі присутні в залі в
школі твоєї не вчили ти б не виграшній
позиції апріоріте знову будеш отим
другим меншим братом знову питатимуть
його бо знатимуть про що його питати
знову слухатимуть його знову ти будеш
підігруючим чи підігруючою чи вважаєте
ви що для того щоб дерусифікувати
Україну достатньо знесення пам'ятників і
існування вулиць звичайно ж недостатньо
звичайно ж потрібно все те чого не
зробили воно і далі потрібне судорожно
українізація під бомбами міської
топоніміки от вона насправді ну так вона
виводить на я я просто І навмисно не
коментую цього всього бо воно ну знаєте
болючого
болюче тому що уявляє собою скажімо всю
міру нашого Не вигластва ну от от воно
повилазило відразу ж від перших
пропозицій І що там берестейську
перейменувати або комусь там розумієте
ну тому хто вніс Цю пропозицію
воно асоціюється бачите з білорусью а з
Білорусією от на нас прийшли
от якраз і прийшли на нас із Білорусі
Так але виросло вже покоління Яке Просто
не знає що це завжди був Що історична
назва цього проспекту брест-литовський
І що це саме берестя даруйте це взагалі
історично це етнічну українські землі
якщо на цій берестейщині люди досі
говорять українською мовою не знаючи що
це українська мова те що це етнічні
українські землі те що ця може назва
станції це остання після перейменування
брест-литовського проспекту це остання
наша зачіпка
Зате берестя і пригадка чим ти берестя
було в українській історії і це поспішне
перейменування тоді коли на мапі міста
немає Я не знаю по-моєму вулиці
старицької черняхівської досі немає і
ніхто і люди не знають Хто це коли такою
треба було коли треба було пояснювати
людям хто такий Чикаленко і чим завдячує
Україна чи калинкою так всі ці сюжети
які е-е
це всеосвіта вірніше брак освіти це все
проблеми нашої все ще пост
колоніального ні осві
асистематизованого якогось от систем
перегляду канону досі відбувається
дискусії серед літературознавців з
приводу
канону української літератури І що з ним
робити бо в нас давити ще далеко в нас
ще по 20-му столітті не всі письменники
опубліковані навіть Елементарно
насправді це речі які Ну коли воно все
знаєте почало вилазити все що не
зроблене Так це що не було зроблене
вчасно От і тепер а тепер треба одразу
всього
шістьма руками так як цього як
восьминога так от всіма лапами всіма
кінцівками одночасно от одночасно щось
робити так як там казав Карлсон малому
пам'ятаєте твоя мама одною рукою ліпила
тюфтельки а другою колотила крему Ну от
якось ця сама мама малого от ми маємо
одною рукою ліпити тюфтельки другою
колотити крем і ще при тому казочку
розказував ти дитині знаєте
Дуже дякую вам за інтерв'ю